З початку війни російські військові завдали прямих збитків інфраструктурі України на $105,5 млрд
або понад 3,1 трлн гривень - таку інформацію у травні оприлюднив дослідницький проєкт "Росія заплатить".
Ініціатива KSE Institute за підтримки Офісу Президента України, Мінекономіки та низки інших міністерств збирає дані про матеріальну шкоду,
завдану громадянам та державі внаслідок російської агресії.
Водночас в Україні і за її межами вже розмірковують про те як, відновлювати інфраструктуру країни.
На тлі постійних заяв і планів про відбудову, українці також щоденно читають новини про обстріли і плани росіян щодо “довготривалої війни”.
Тож розмови про відбудову багатьом здаються передчасними.
Анна Кирій - архітекторка і представниця Архітектурної палати України.
Разом з командою Кирій досліджує приклади з історії, щоб зрозуміти, коли найкраще почати відбудову.
За словами архітекторки, зволікати не варто.
Чому треба думати про відбудову зараз? По-перше, це вже інформація з аналітики всіх кейсів,
які ми збирали після Другої світової війни - вони починали одразу.
Одна з основних причин - люди бралися за відбудову, оскільки розуміли, що це їхній шанс зробити житло й інфраструктури такими,
які підходять саме для них. Замість того, щоб чекати, поки ініціативу перейме нова чи стара влада, люди брали проєктні рішення у свої руки.
Щоправда, архітекторка вказує, що зараз час ретельно планувати відбудову, але не починати масштабні будівельні роботи.
Адже ризик повторних руйнувань зі сторони Росії зберігається.
Проєкти треба робити. Щоб як тільки у нас була перемога, на наступний день ми могли виходити на ті будівельні майданчики.
Я вважаю, що проєкти треба готувати, готувати візію, містобудівну документацію, генеральні плани, всі-всі аналітичні матеріали.
Щоб всі архітектори, коли повернуться з фронту - а от вам, дивіться, ви можете це брати і з цим працювати.
Міркуваннями уряду щодо відбудови у травні поділився прем’єр-міністр Денис Шмигаль.
Згідно з планом, перша стадія - оперативне тимчасове відновлення.
Це побудова тимчасового житла для переміщених осіб або відносно швидкі ремонтні роботи.
Друга стадія - це початок відбудови одразу після закінчення воєнних дій.
Третій етап - велике повноцінне відновлення країни.
Доцільність поетапності підтверджує і Синтія Кук, очільниця Групи оборонно-промислових ініціатив Центру стратегічних і міжнародних досліджень.
За словами експертки, Україна має визначити, що необхідно відновлювати першим.
Виклик у тому, щоб вирішити, що відбудовувати першим. Зараз видається, що потуги росіян сконцентровані на сході і півдні,
тому можна починати з якоїсь безпечної дистанції. Звісно, це вже почалося, оскільки люди працюють над тим,
щоб відбудовувати свої домівки, школи і місця підприємницької діяльності.
Експерти зазначають, що створити універсальну програму відбудови всієї України практично неможливо -
в областях і населених пунктах різняться масштаби руйнувань.
Десь були пошкоджені окремі дороги й будинки, а десь - майже вщент зруйновані міста.
За словами архітекторки Анни Кирій, важливо враховувати контекст кожної локації, а також потреби майбутніх мешканців.
Виділили якусь земельну ділянку десь біля Збаража, Львова. У чистому полі.
І там побудували житловий квартал. Ну, я не впевнена, що людям там буде добре. Людина має приїхати в існуючу урбаністичу структуру.
Де у неї тут кафе, школа, садочок, я не знаю, місце для мангалу.
Також експерти сходяться на думці, що має працювати принцип ВВВ - build back better,
за яким вся відновлена інфраструктура буде якіснішою, ніж вона була до війни.
Наприклад, немає сенсу відбудовувати "панельки", небезпечні транспортні розвʼязки або планувати житлові квартали без рекреаційних зон.
Або ми для себе зробимо той поштовх важливий, який перетворить наші міста на процвітаючі економічно успішні, або проґавимо цю штуку.
Планується, що процес відновлення буде подібний до "Плану Маршалла" -
програми економічної допомоги європейським державам після Другої світової війни.
Нещодавно прем'єр Шмигаль зазначив, що план відновлення України об’єднає країни від США до Японії та від Австралії до Канади.
ЄС уже пообіцяв взяти ледь не провідну роль у відновленні України.
З цією метою у Євросоюзі створять трастовий фонд солідарності, який профінансує інвестиції та реформи.
ЄС вже створив стратегічний план післявоєнного відновлення України.
Згідно з документом, відбудова зруйнованої війною інфраструктури займе понад 10 років.
На Економічному форумі у Давосі президент Володимир Зеленський запропонував партнерам України
взяти на себе патронаж над тими областями, містами та галузями України, які постраждали від війни, щоб спільно забезпечити їхнє відновлення.
Данії, до прикладу, президент України запропонував опікуватися Миколаєвом.
За словами Джеймса Ходсона, співзасновника проєкту Економісти для України, ще один виклик - це грамотна координація всіх партнерів.
Зараз немає формального алгоритму, як усе буде відбуватися.
Будуть багато груп в Україні і поза нею, які будуть підтримувати і координувати довготривалий план для України.
Один з найсвіжіших планів - це з Центру європейських політичних досліджень, ми також залучені до них.
І він збирає багато маленьких шматочків докупи. Однак відбудова України буде великими рухом, очолювати який будуть українці.
Також, враховуючи такий спектр учасників, важливо забезпечити моніторинг належного використання грошей,
тобто застосувати механізми, які унеможливлять корупцію.
Є механізми, які допоможуть нам більш прозоро відстежувати, куди йдуть гроші.
Щоб розуміти, що доцільно, що ні. І робити це треба на рівні громад, з низів до верхівки,
замість того, щоб викидати сотні мільярдів доларів чи євро чи гривень у країні.
Надважливим завданням буде впевнитись, що гроші  будуть витрачатися правильно.
Частково держава вже почала збирати інформацію щодо руйнувань від місцевого населення і оцінювати завдані війною збитки.
А саме - люди можуть подати заявку щодо пошкоджень їхнього житла через додаток Дія або до ЦНАПу.
Після цього треба очікувати на повідомлення про початок процедури оцінки та компенсації.
Однак самі процедури уряд ще детально не прописав, а отже, кошти навряд чи вдасться отримати оперативно.
Місцеві адміністрації також будуть опікуватися відбудовою.
Наприклад, мер Києва Віталій Кличко заявив, що у Києві починають реконструкцію житлових будинків і приміщень соціальної інфраструктури,
пошкоджених обстрілами російських військ. На ці потреби столиця виділяє з бюджету майже 600 мільйонів гривень.
Очевидно, що самотужки Україна не впорається з тим масштабом робіт, які необхідно провести, щоб відновити житловий фонд й інфраструктуру.
За словами премʼєр-міністра Дениса Шмигаля, відбудова та відновлення України коштуватиме щонайменше 600 млрд доларів.
За понад три місяці повномасштабної війни Україна отримала 4,5 мільярда євро фінансової допомоги від міжнародних партнерів,
а також 500 млн доларів від Світового банку.
Міністри фінансів Великої сімки у травні домовилися про 18,4 млрд доларів на допомогу Україні в оплаті рахунків у найближчі місяці.
Також на відбудову України планують направити арештовані російські активи в Європі.
Наприклад, в Ірландії вже заморозили понад 1 млрд євро російських активів, а кілька міністрів країни заявили,
що ці гроші могли б піти на відбудову України після арешту.
Схожі розмови ведуться й у Великобританії та інших країнах Великої сімки.
Знайти легальні способи зробити це - це основні задачі багатьох країн, їхніх спецслужб.
Я думаю, що це невід’ємно, що Росія буде залучена до процесу відбудови України.
Та це все ще буде крапля в океані. Відбудова України вимагатиме системної і грамотної роботи,
під час якої потреби українців мають бути на першому місці.
А уряд повинен бути надати партнерам і донорам гарантії,
що Україна не просто отримуватиме гроші, а буде рухатися в напрямку європейських цінностей.